Washington a autorisé à donner le feu
vert à un vaccin pour le moins illusité
je vous dis tout de suite vous verrez
pas d'aiguilles c'est un vaccin pour les
abeilles c'est la première fois qu'un
tel traitement est autorisé pour des
insectes alors naturellement que ça
pique notre curiosité également celle de
Renault à gagner qui est notre
chroniqueur à l'environnement et qui
vient de retrouver alors bonjour bonjour
au début d'année alors vous allez me
dire on veut protéger les abeilles bon
on a entendu parler de maladie puis de
virus dernièrement alors on va les
protéger de quoi spécifiquement dans le
cas de vaccin si c'est d'une maladie
dévastatrice qu'on appelle la loque
américaine ça c'est une maladie qui est
causée par une bactérie qui s'attaque
aux larves des abeilles et qui peut
anéantir une ruche en moins de trois
semaines si les antibiotiques sont pas
très efficaces contre cette bactérie là
donc une fois qu'une ruche est infectée
on n'a pas d'autre moyenne méthode que
de brûler la ruche et tous les objets
qui sont en train en contact avec pour
éviter que la bactérie se propage aux
autres donc on comprend l'intérêt d'un
vaccin avec une méthode de aussi
drastique et là je vous rassure tout de
suite m'attarder comme vous le disiez un
peu plus tôt on pas des abeilles avec
une petite aiguille pour les piquer
c'est un vaccin alimentaire donc on met
le produit dans la gelée royale donc
dans qui est consommé par la reine la
reine va développer une immunité et
ensuite elle va la transmettre à sa
descendance donc c'est cette diffusion
là en fait à partir de la reine qui rend
ce vaccin là intéressant en fait qui est
vraiment possible quasiment comme un
virus sans que quelqu'un qui est le
virus c'est le même principe finalement
presque est-ce que est-ce que ça déjà
été fait sur les insectes des vaccins
comme ça non c'est le premier vaccin
pour les insectes en fait on n'avait
jamais pensé qu'un vaccin pouvait être
possible pour les insectes jusqu'à
maintenant parce que on croyait que
c'est trop différent du reste des
vertébrés mais des vertébrés même des
mammifères en fait les abeilles ont même
pas de d'anticorps donc on est assez
loin de l'idée qu'on soit habituellement
des vaccins mais on a fini par mieux
comprendre leur système immunitaire un
peu comment le stimuler et c'est ça qui
est amené à cette avancée quand même
très récente il y a une étude qui était
réalisée l'an dernier qui a montré que
le vaccin était efficace et sécuritaire
pour les abeilles c'est ça qui a fait
que début de l'année donc le ministère
de l'Agriculture américain l'a approuvé
pour les Etats-Unis donc c'est la
semaine dernière bon ça arrive pas
arrivé un meilleur moment pour les
apiculteurs il me semble je me suis
implique quel était le problème mais je
sais que j'ai parlé à l'apiculteur qui
nous décrivait qu'on avait un problème
avec les ruches qui perdait et perdait
de ses abeilles beaucoup alors ce qui
peut avoir une application
tout ça c'est sûr que ça peut aider les
chiffres varient selon les années puis
les pays mais les pollinisateurs sont en
déclin partout c'est sûr que créer un
vaccin pour les abeilles ça va pas
régler le problème c'est un problème qui
est très complexe ça c'est inclut les
pesticides la perte des écosystèmes
d'autres maladies la crise climatique
donc la liste est longue mais si on peut
protéger les abeilles d'une menace ça
peut augmenter leur résilience face à
toutes les autres et c'est ça qui fait
qu'on ce genre de vaccin là on risque
d'en voir de plus en plus apparaître au
cours des prochaines années bon on
change on reste dans l'agriculture parce
que bon on en a tous besoin n'est-ce pas
vous voulez nous parler d'érosion il y a
des études ou des chercheurs qui se
penchent peut-être sur des solutions
ouais ben l'érosion des sols c'est une
grave conséquence de l'agriculture
moderne donc si on laisse pas au sol le
temps de se régénérer entre les cultures
la proche de surface donc que la terre
arabes va se dégrader va finir par
s'assécher partir au vent et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on cette érosion là se
passe beaucoup plus vite que prévu et
des études qui montrent que ça a lieu un
rythme qui fait qui se traduit par des
centaines de milliards de tonnes de
terres arables qui partent comme ça au
vent qui sont partis au vent en fait
depuis les le dernier siècle donc faut
vraiment trouver des solutions pour
régler le problème et si on pouvait
laisser les plantes agricoles dans le
sol plus longtemps au lieu de les
arracher systématiquement chaque année
on aiderait à réduire le problème et ça
ça a été une des un des sujets auxquels
s'attaquer des avancées scientifiques
les plus importantes de 2022 selon le
magazine Science dans leur top 10 c'est
en décembre dernier c'est des chercheurs
qui ont présenté un plan de riz vivace
donc les plants de riz on les arrache
systématiquement à chaque récolte ça ça
contribue à la dégradation des sols mais
cette nouvelle variété là qui est née
d'un croisement d'une variété asiatique
et africaine elle elle a une longévité
de 4 ans on peut la laisser dans le sol
pendant quatre années elle est aussi
elle produit autant de riz que les
variétés qu'on arrache tout le temps et
selon dans l'étude ne pas avoir arraché
ces plans là constamment ça peut mener
ça mène en fait à un enrichissement des
sols en éléments nutritif quand même
temps ça coûte moins cher exploiter des
rizières si on n'a pas arracher les
plants de riz tout le temps donc ça
vient aider ça vient aider plusieurs
éléments en même temps on parle d'une
baisse de presque 50 % des coûts
d'exploitation des rivières donc c'est
ça montre que l'avance c'est énorme ça
montre que l'avancée de ce genre de
connaissances là c'est ça peut avoir des
conséquences pour l'environnement mais
aussi pour l'économie bon mais une autre
machine à ratoise qui va falloir acheter
peut-être pour récolter ce thriller
merci beaucoup d'être la semaine
prochaine ça fait plaisir au revoir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]